this is Kimberly Leonard back at home
after recording one episode of The Sky
News Daily we had a really interesting
discussion about the BBC's response to
the claims about one of its biggest
presenters that is still there in the
fee to listen to
this emergency episode acts as an
addition to that because just after we
finished some new significant details
about this story immersed I'll tell you
what they are and then we've got to
guest ready to go through them so the
BBC has reported a statement from the
lawyer representing the young person
involved in this and it says their
mother's claims are quote rubbish and
the story was quote totally wrong
the Lesser adds nothing inappropriate or
unlawful has taken place the sun has
responded saying we've seen evidence to
support the concerns of two parents it's
now for the BBC to properly investigate
with me now is the media lawyer Matthew
Gill thanks so much for coming on at
such short notice what's your reaction
to these latest developments
look it's a really difficult time for
all of the parties involved the sun went
into this article no doubt having you
know done a lot of research they will
have worked with the mother who has made
these allegations to make sure that they
felt comfortable that what they were
reporting was as accurate or at least
you know get themselves as comfortable
as possible that it was accurate
um and now of course they're hearing
that the individual involved the young
person involved may not agree with that
version of events and so it's quite a
challenging time for the Sun and also
for the individuals involved of course
as for the BBC they will carry on with
their investigation I'm sure and will
carry on following the rules that they
have set out for themselves in occasions
of problems such as this
the police involvement the producer said
that there was no investigation that's
what the police said at that point when
the police were involved did the BBC
investigation pause the police say
there's no investigation so the BBC
investigation picks up internally is
that how it would have worked out that
is likely because you know you don't
want to get in the way of a police
investigation and I think if the police
had said actually we're going to step in
here and investigate this the the
internal investigation would likely have
paused during that time okay so on
Friday we had the first story from the
Sun and then every day we've had
additions what does this mean now for
the sun in terms of this story
legally for them well as I say the sun
will have taken steps to make sure that
they were comfortable that what they
were reporting was true but there are
always multiple sides to stories we just
wouldn't always expect it you know the
mother and the son or daughter to to be
on different pages as they are here in
terms of Legally if it is proven that
what the sun has reported is false in
any way then they could be liable for
defamation the the BBC presenter
involved could choose to sue the Sun for
damages because of the damage to his
reputation
so so the latest Revelations come from
the alleged victims lawyer who wrote to
the BBC so will that obviously now play
a part in that BBC investigation they
will for sure uh consider that and
they'll be having much more extensive
conversations with that person too
because they'll they will want to
understand all of the facts understand
whether the BBC presenter has done
anything wrong
um by their description not by the
individual's description but they will
of course
um take into account the fact that it
sounds like the young person has no
complaint here now on on the previous
episode we discussed title privacy laws
and this it really would just reiterate
a need for them doesn't it careers
reputations they're all at stake in a
situation like this yeah it's a really
difficult balance between the rights of
the individual their their privacy
rights and whether
um they should be named and accused
publicly why when actually there is no
police investigation let alone a charge
versus the rights of the public to know
when a high-profile public figures
um have done wrong so it's a really
tricky balance a couple of hours ago
many people will have been saying we
have a right to know we should be told
who this person is it's in the public
interest but now that we've seen this
letter from the alleged victim's lawyer
saying actually there are there is no
complaint here nothing unlawful or
inappropriate has happened
um you know of course people will be
thinking goodness
um we were just asking for this BBC
presented to be named but perhaps there
was nothing wrong and maybe these are
false allegations
and the other side of that obviously is
that those presenters who were wrongly
named on social media there's just been
so much said on social media since the
story broke there is a risk of defaming
someone if you take to social media and
think it's just a free-for-all and you
can say whatever you want about someone
yeah there is a real risk when people
make allegations like this on Twitter or
other social media platforms that they
could be sued for defamation most of the
claims that we see go through our courts
or you know before courts in the in the
pre-action stage relate to social media
allegations and the allegations that
people have been making about a range of
celebrities are serious and um
defamatory and could harm their
reputation and so if anyone tweets or
retweets in facts allegations that
celebrities have been up to no good they
do risk being sued and the costs of
Defending such a legal claim are really
high running into the tens and hundreds
of thousands of pounds
and this update it's an update but it
really just reiterates doesn't it that
we really don't know much
I think that's right we still don't know
very much about what's happened here we
have one person's version of events who
we understand is the mother of the
person uh the young person involved so
she herself wasn't involved in this
alleged wrongdoing personally and that
makes it difficult for us to understand
what's going on but no doubt the BBC
will be speaking to both of the
individuals at the center of this and
will be trying to unearth whether
anything has actually gone wrong
[Music]
that was Matthew Gayle media lawyer and
this episode was produced by Rosie
Jenner the editor was Paul stanworth